according to the CDC Nevada has the
highest concentration of a so-called
superbug that's causing some problems
Nationwide and a high concentration of
the deaths also here in the Silver State
Ryan mathey joins us now live to break
down the infection where it's happening
and why Nevada see a number is so high
yeah Brian and Kirsten Canada Oris it's
nothing new the first case was reported
actually over a decade ago but now the
CDC is listed it as an urgent thread
this map from the CDC shows the hot
spots Across the Nation health
professionals are working to best treat
the treatment resistant infections and
that's key here in Nevada as we lead the
nation for most infections with no clear
reason as to why oh
a form of yeast not usually harmful to
healthy people but increasingly harmful
to patients in the hospital Canada Oris
it's a fungus an infection that can
cause shaking fevers chills and if it
gets into the bloodstream damage to
internal organs infectious disease
Professor Dr William Schaffner says when
patients are infected they are put in
their private rooms in isolation and
health care workers wear gowns and
gloves caring for them so they won't
spread it to others an infection most
commonly seen in hospital settings where
catheters and blood tubes provide an
easy entry inside the body to those most
prone to sickness Nevada California and
Florida leave the country more so in
Nevada than anywhere else the CDC
reported 16 percent of all cases
nationally were in Nevada last year
that's nearly 400 cases out of over 2300
but according to Dr Mark Khan dean of
unlv's Kirk accordion school of medicine
the reason why is unknown it may have
something to do with our climate
it may have something to do with our
hospitals
and I just don't think we have an answer
as to why that is and until they learn
more infections are rejecting the three
kinds of anti-fungal drugs available on
the market so over time we're gonna have
to find better ways to treat the
infection
now another doctor researching the
fungus said that they've recently
discovered a compound that seems
effective against candina Oris although
testing to prove that could take many
months more before potential use to
treat infections Brian